[Music]
okay so I'm very extroverted be careful
I think college is overrated for the
vast majority of Majors this is coming
from someone who went to a really good
school and had a scholarship forward all
my friends who I've talked to graduate
from college most of them are miserable
with their jobs I think if you're doing
stem you're doing science then yeah go
to college but for most Majors I think
college is overrated and it's not going
to get you the kind of lifestyle that
you think it's going to get you I think
the best advice is to find a skill that
people need so for example I have a
friend who works at Trader Joe's but he
does like you know helps me out and
takes videos with me so I got him to
start a photography business right
because people need photo shoots like a
lot of people have really bad photos
right so his whole angle is going to be
taking photos for people's tinders so I
think anyone can find a little niche and
get really good at something that people
need people desire I think that for some
people again if you're doing stem go to
college for everything else I think it's
kind of a waste of time
you're about to open up a can of whoop
ass right now I want to disagree with
you and Adam is going to catch some
bullets on the side okay
um when you tune into these kinds of
shows and you get advice for how to
manage your Finance to be successful
this advice is being applied to like the
top one percent of people for most
people it doesn't matter right when I
was looking at a carpet cleaner there is
no like invest in yourself or you know
figure out the skill set that you have
to like you know do things that are
better than other people most people
just don't have the types of skills
naturally in areas that aren't in ultra
high demand if you did most people could
be successful or be in you know these
positions but probably one person you
see that you know was able to start a
YouTube business there's a million
people behind him that tried and failed
miserably
um the reason why I like college is
because college is just a very safe and
secure path to an almost guaranteed end
goal where you have like some sort of
job that's paying you like a decent
amount of money assuming you don't do
anything stupid in the process like
going to out-of-state schools paying
tuition abroad for like a random arts
degree that's not going to pay you
anything assuming you're not coming from
a wealthy family um I just like college
because they put you on sale a path if
there are things that you feel like you
have an aptitude for you can do better
like if you're incredibly entertaining
if you've got a skill set that's high in
demand in certain industries then yeah
sure like try there but for the vast
majority of people listening you know
like as much as you talk about like
hustle culture and Drop Shipping and all
that [ __ ] like there'll be people that I
see online talking about having like
seven streams of like [ __ ] uh revenue
and they're making like 22 a month on
each of them like these people are
busting their ass working all day you
know reading white peppers I can't
understand about crypto that they're
going to go broke on you know trying to
drop ship on the side and selling like
52 cents of [ __ ] on Amazon and that's
just the reality for most people so yeah
I like the I like the solid reliable
path assuming you don't have another
skill that you can lean into what but
those people oh sorry do you do you
agree that some majors are useless I'm
just no major is useless some Majors
don't make money but people talk about
useless Majors like the only point of
college is to make money when it comes
down to Roi yeah which people don't
understand of course Roi but but
when we talk about Roi The Return part
there of that investment the return can
be cultural we need Art majors we need
history majors we need English Majors
it's an important part of having a
functioning Society not at College
shouldn't just be a jobs training
program there should be other things
that we learn and we have like uh
exemplified in society as well I think
yeah if you're going there purely for
the education fact and just want to get
like an education then sure but most
people aren't doing it they're doing it
because they want to get a job and most
of the people like the people who follow
like I don't know marketing majors or
accounting Majors they all pretty much
hate their jobs like none of them are
really happy from what I've seen yeah
but I mean if they would have gone to
school they're going to be happy anyway
like what I mean it's not like they
would have like flunked school or not
done it they're like oh I'm so much
happier working at Wendy's I mean I
agree with you that like there's a lot
of glorify things like Drop Shipping
that probably are not for the average
person but there's little things you can
do like video editing if you can learn
video editing there's going to be a
whole bunch of people who will hire you
no I'm gonna hold you guys to this how
many people realistically the percentage
of people listening right now could make
money video editing on YouTube it's like
less than one percent if there is a good
video editor and you email me I will
give you a job yeah but the problem is
how much money could that person make no
I I actually disagree there are
about and you had to train them two
people in third world countries yeah
okay okay I'm glad you brought that up
because they're gonna say you're hiring
people in India to Video Edit which
makes even harder for the average person
listening to make money videos so if you
want to pay somebody like you know five
bucks or 20 bucks to edit a video for
the people listening to home that's even
more difficult for you the guy the guy
in Nigeria makes roughly 10K a month
editing 10K a month okay so if you're a
Nigerian you're listening then I guess
10K a month that's the king of Nigerians
no he um because he just does so much
he's so he started hiring his friends
like he did yeah yeah because the
reality is somebody that's hired video
editors even if the majority of video
editors that know how to edit videos and
apply to like positions to work for me
most of these people aren't even that
good so the average viewer at home is
not going to pick up video editing
unless you've got like an aptitude for
it but in that case you're already like
a very slim minority okay can I can I
just kind of like your show here's what
I'm gonna do I'm gonna tighten this up
and put the circle together everyone has
a point here because what we're talking
about is essentially is you got to
figure out what's right for you the
problem is that we all have to make
these life decisions at 18. what are you
going to do for the rest of your life
it's like dude I don't know I'm 18 I'm
just trying to get late okay but the
problem is what major you're gonna pick
what are you going to go to Roi what the
hell is RI can barely even spell and I
got to spell Roi what you said exactly
was yeah you need music Majors you need
people this is the same argument that
people make where they're like you tell
Adam you you tell people to save that
money save that money we need to spend
money so the economy stays on I'm like
oh so now it's your [ __ ] job to keep
the economy alive no it's your job to
keep your economy alive so yes I do
agree we need music majors and theater
majors and art majors and Majors that
don't pay [ __ ] but do you want to be
dead broke because you're contributing
to society I don't know about that okay
wait hold on just it's such a dumb straw
man if you're broke as [ __ ] you come
from a broke family you shouldn't be
going to school to be a PhD history
major right obviously I agree with that
but I say like for people from middle
class families that want to go to school
and do like other things like history I
just don't like that there's there's
this concept of like a worthless degree
and it's like knowledge and education
and like the expansion of like our whole
understanding of the world old I think
it's important
I'm not going to tell the kid from the
projects would you agree that some
Majors don't have a good Roi if if
you're only measuring return in terms of
income yeah for sure okay okay I have a
worthless degree I I went to BU business
school I have a marketing degree it's
been completely worthless for my career
yeah mine's been worthless too people I
know have worthless we're saying two
separate things and they can both be
valid what he's saying is hey if you go
to school hear me out if you go to
school and you get a degree there's
going to be some Merit in that there's
gonna even if you don't kill it make a
lot of money and have debt you're still
contributing to society you're still
gonna have a job you're gonna have all
that and then the other position is like
yeah well the kind of the reason that
you're going to school and getting
taking out college loans and getting
degrees is so you can make more money in
life if not just don't go to college so
like there's it's kind of two sides of
the same coin does that make sense I
don't know the only Merit that's been to
my degree is the fact that I got to
party a lot in college that's the only
Merit to have you can say that for the
numbers the marketing degree I have it
has been completely worthless for the
market in my business I have learned
more watching YouTube videos about
marketing than I did during four years
in college and I actually had good
grades 100 [ __ ] percent agree again
specific subset of people that you see
on stage like the people that can't
learn aren't making it up here they're
at home earning nothing trying to make
it online doing some crazy side hustle
like following Instagram stories most
people can't make it in the YouTuber
most people can't self-teach if they
could schools wouldn't exist yeah well
one of the things is tutors one of the
thing I always say is most people or
most people yeah okay there's very few a
students there's very few F students
most people are in between for every
[ __ ] valedictorian there's another
idiot that didn't show up the class
everyone was kind of between it's your
job to improve yourself what's the term
that they talk about learning on
yourself
what is that exactly when you can just
learn on your own it's exactly what you
could do on YouTube I think YouTube is
one of the best inventions ever if you
are a auto Didact and you're willing to
improve by yourself and you want to just
spend dedicate days months years of your
life learning oh my God the things you
could do on YouTube and Google back in
the day you're 32 34 34. you look you
got great skin though how old are you
I'm 33 33 you're 26 not still 21 somehow
but back in the day what we used to have
uh encyclopedia the card catalogs you
young kids have no I I feel like I sound
like an 80 year old man right now you'll
have no idea how hard it was you could
just Google something YouTube something
instacart something Uber something
everything's at the tip of your future
but I think it's important to recognize
that like we say that like all the
information is available on the internet
if people could learn on their own we
would have the [ __ ] smartest Society
in the world right now everybody
learning everything most people are most
which is why most people need teachers
and colleges in college I'd also like to
offer um I know you said as many of you
know I was just banned on Tick Tock and
we are demonetized on a daily basis on
this platform if you want to help please
consider sending a super thanks below
every donation helps and it helps make
what we do possible